ora tutto bene ho mangiato bene
benissimo guardi ma eccezionale proprio
[Musica]
guardi io non sono una di quelle che fa
i complimenti per poi farsi farlo sconto
è no anzi chissà cosa faccio adesso vado
sul mio gruppo di facebook che siamo
circa una sessantina di amici della mia
età di gente che spende e spande e le
faccio pubblicità locale vedova come che
non rientro gente che va gente che viene
le faccio guadagnare tanti sordini
scontino amicizia non è uno scontro
proprio un gesto di solidarietà scusa
scusa ti schifo io non ho mica ordinato
il tonno scottato al cappello ma che
cos'è guarda ma ce ne sono 4 5 ma che
schifo che mancanza d'igiene
vorrei che ci vuole un attimo io faccio
una foto la pubblico su tripadvisor.it
canali giu le traci nette e dice addio
al ristorantino io guardi non è mai
successo glielo cambio immediatamente
certo perché io tempo da perdere ed ero
no guarda guarda dimentico questo triste
episodio lo mangio ma come minimo non me
lo fai pagare senza siamo nel settore
quindi ci capiamo e we understand
pitscheider allora un bel filetto è alla
piastra con il sangue proprio che riesce
poi all animale vivo vivo che mi parla
anche se vuole e poi una patella e al
forno americana è non facciamo quelle
buren a te che le patate nostrane e poi
mi fa una bella riduzione di aceto
balsamico è un po di rafano e se
possibile
adorerei una purea di zucca australia e
guardi provo a chiedere ma la zucca
australiana non so
trattiamo pieno ottobre non mi avete
laggiù cast ma io non ho parole
guardi mi è passata alla fame cioè ma
noi ristoratori di una volta è abbiamo
l'orticello km zero dietro al ristorante
è questa la gente che fa girare il
business della ristorazione ma penso che
ti guardi sono affamatissima allora
prenderei un ma cukor all 1 spaghettino
nella di secchia e perché no anche un
tono ascoltata pistacchio mi raccomando
abbondanti aic a far guarire l'attesa
aveva portato anche corsi grazie gene
prossimo
ecco sui piatti signora arriva anche il
terzo adesso bari che sono pieno se non
è un problema vi può riportare cucina e
ovviamente non vi faccio pagare perché
non mangiate
mi dispiace senta guardi troppo lungo
questo menu e mi affido a lei mi
consigli di lei qualcosa di buono di
particolare è qualcosa di tipico del
vostro ristorante si allora io le
consiglio una carbonara di pesce
guanciale perfetto connubio tra mare
monti un mio branzino scottato con sale
rosa di malaja e il tartufo dall'altra
bianco oppure se preferisce un roll
corri sono haller di seppia e astice o
anche molto particolare con ascoltato
chissà chi e con quelli cha guardi
sembrano molto buoni però effettivamente
avevo in mente qualcos'altro non so
magari vi fa un'insalatina è con un po
di maris i pomodorini niente tonno
niente mozzarella proprio semplice è
grazie grazie mille ecco che delicatezza
lo sa che se non col piatto quando lo
fanno pagare è ma che mo di tono ma le
pare
ma di nuovo ma sa che se reso la pro
misfits a tutti faccio vi facciamo
vivere di meno davanti a tutti e mi sono
appena fatto la piega lei veramente poco
professionale come si chiama the fighter
scoprendo telefono faccio commenti su
chi passa nelle mani di scienziato tenta
io solo vincere perché sono stato a
tokyo parecchie volte è uso grafica il
santa di tokyo è io me ne intendo
dispero perché questo non è neanche
parente del sushi giapponese
guardi ma che cos'è c'è il riso e
sproporzionato rispetto alla quantità di
pesce il pesce troppo freddo questo
pesce può arrivare la congestione non
capisco perché richiamate le giapponesi
su quello next gen bagarre si guardi gli
sono intollerante al glutine e al
lattosio
non posso mangiare frutta secca non
posso mangiare crostacei e zuccheri
che cosa mi consiglia quali posso farle
un filetto di salmone semplice lo guardi
non posso mangiare neanche pesce
signorina questo comunque è un
ristorante di pesce e ho capito mi vuole
dire che in cucina non c'è niente che
non sia pesce cioè siete veramente così
delicati per farlo insalata ma io non
posso mangiare insalata verde signorina
mi dispiace ma non so proprio come
aiutarla salario non sappiamo ancora
cucina guardi sono super super di fretta
prendo questo qui è proprio loach e mi
raccomando veloce sanità finta ma lei
prende in giro le rito veloce son
passati due minuti
signorino il suo piatto in cultura no
guardi non ho parole ci ha detto che
sono di fretta che non vi portiamo me ne
vado ciao tenta un informazione ma
questo simon e è da dove viene qual è la
sua convenienza della norvegia e il
taglieggiamento o e pescato
assolutamente d'allevamento
ma ce l'avete l'abbattitore fate le cose
per bene
sì ne abbiamo ben due siete a norma e
poi volevo dire questa cosa il filetto
di cose che ho preso con il mare
paghiamoci kiter no quello non è
assolutamente filetto di kobe secondo me
non l'avete massaggiato bene con la
viola non è neanche lontanamente
paragonabile al diletto di kobe e
proprio ordinarietà ha poco da guardare
amico ti lo fa perché io manco al
ristorante a quanto cena tutti i giorni
da quando sono nato quindi ne capisco
per non parlare del fatto che non mi
perdo neanche una puntata di masterchef
quindi è ormai sono professionista e
sono del settore ha poco da fare così e
ne so più di lei
pronto per l'ordinaria signora scelta ma
lei ha visto un parente
che vive a bergamo alta no perché siete
mi ricorda tantissimo questa mia vecchia
fiamma di quando ero giovane io ero
innamorata persa lutero tema la morosa
quindi è ci vedevamo di nascosto niente
lo penso di vista è perché siamo
cresciuti tutti e due lui è andato a
vivere aiutano buonasera buonasera
allora vorrei questo panino qui
gentilmente se al posto del pane rimette
il pane integrale
meglio se con semi di zucca i pomodori
mi raccomando biologici
l'insalata mi sostituisca la lattuga con
della rucola e il formaggio per favore
stagionato di capra perché quello fresco
non lo digerisco se possibile condire
con questa salsa che l'ha fatta mia
mamma quindi di lei mi fido grazie
si è fatto un grande amore vita ma
cambiando argomento parliamo di robe da
giovani lei li segue gli youtubers è
perché io la seguo una che pazzesca si
chiama ma rinaldi già è la segua su
instagram e mi raccomando anche il
canale youtube altintop varie cose si
chiama sempre marina ufficio quindi le
consiglio proprio di iscriversi e lei è
molto simpatica perché insomma fa queste
mutazioni
[Musica]